(slow piano music)
- You gotta be a certain type of person
to get into flying without an engine.
(bouncy, upbeat music)
The fact that we're able
to leave the ground,
leave everything behind,
and fly through the skies
on nylon and strings, is exceptional.
(bouncy piano music)
The Rat Race is a seven day
long paragliding competition
with 200 participants, that also serves
as the U.S. National
Paragliding Championship.
(wind rumbling)
My name is Nick Greece.
I'm a professional paraglider pilot.
A paragliding race is very
similar to a sailboat race.
They race around buoys.
We race around several
different GPS coordinates
that we have to hit along the way.
Each morning, the race course is determined
by the weather for that day,
and a course typically ranges
from 40 to 70 miles long.
The first person to finish
the course every day
gets 1,000 points.
If someone's five seconds
back, they get 995
and so on and so forth.
And then at seven days, you
add up all your scores together
and whoever has the most points wins.
I grew up in Long Island in a
suburb close to New York City.
I went to Beloit College in Wisconsin,
and after that I returned to Manhattan
to take a job at a PR firm.
My second day at work
was September 11th, 2001,
so I was walking to work
and I saw the first plane
hit the World Trade
Center from the street.
I don't know if that
played a significant role,
but it played some role in me deciding
that I needed to do
something sooner than later
if I wasn't completely
satisfied with what I was doing.
So I sold all my possessions
and lived out of my car,
and all I did was fly.
I've dedicated my life since
2001 to flying paragliders.
For many years I've been one
of the top pilots in the U.S.,
and that to me is a sign of success.
Watching the start of a paragliding race
is a sight to behold.
100 pilots launching off
a hill and then getting up
into the starting paddock,
which is what we call a gaggle.
The start, it can be a chaotic experience
of people that are
trying to get to the top
so that they're in the best position,
so everybody jockeying for position.
Once that starts, it's
just a glorious experience
of rallying through mountain
ranges for a whole day
with your friends.
After seven days, you're pretty exhausted,
but that's also the real joy in doing
any kind of endurance event.
Just like with anything,
whether you're trading stocks
or riding bikes, or flying paragliders,
you're always trying to make progress
and increase your ability to succeed.
And paragliding competition
is a beautiful example
of pitting your skills, not
only against your competitors,
but against the elements.
(lively, bouncy music)
(chiming)